this is your second romantic movie
together but um your characters are
obviously in a very different place than
they were in shall we dance so I was
wondering what it's like what it was
like to kind of do this sort of story
together again
um no after you got strong well it was a
different story so we felt actually it's
the third one we've done we've
discovered it's the third one
but I I think what's great about Susan
from my point of view is that
she can do anything
and she's still a human being still that
vulnerable human being comes through and
she loves playing as most actors do
playing extreme characters but there's
still always that human being
and and I can trust that that that
reality is always there to play with
and that's great fun because you know
you always have a connection it's not
someone just off doing their own thing
and
and being flamboyant and and chewing the
scenery but there's still that
vulnerable human being that you can play
with and from an actor's point of view
that's that's where the fun is it's like
you're you're with a living breathing
human being with all the flaws and all
the problems and everything else but but
it's still a living human being
situation
I feel the same way about Richard but
also he I feel safe
working with him which makes me braver
because I know that he's present and he
listens yeah that's a good point because
it's the same with me everyone here
wanted everyone to be good yeah their
best selves
and to bring out the best in each other
you know we were very nurturing with
each other and taking care of each other
as you mentioned this is very different
from the from the other films that
you've done together and I felt like
this leaned more into the comedy side of
things versus The Romantics I was
wondering how it felt to kind of play
that play that side up a little bit well
play is a very good point word to say I
mean I it felt playful it felt
um
again
you you know safe in a way yeah safe and
and that's when you can be playful
because I knew he had his thing down and
I could therefore have my thing and that
he would support me and there was you
know this I mean there wasn't a lot of
improvisation but there was some
give to how things came down and how we
expressed it and you know how we danced
and
um that was really I mean that's why you
do it really is because we all want
connection not so much to be seen seen
by an audience but the feeling I do
anyway the collaboration of having a
tribe of people that are putting this
together and the connection that you
have when you have a moment with
somebody for me that's extraordinary so
if you can find other actors that are
prepared so they're not thrown if you do
something a little bit different that's
when it's the most fun
um so you did speak a lot about kind of
playing off of each other and there's a
lot of great Duo scenes to Trio scenes
early on in the movie but the back half
is this kind of mad cap Comedy of Errors
sort of Ensemble piece so what were some
of the highlights of filming that kind
of chaotic energy Michael was good at
that actually I think Michael the writer
director Michael Jacobs is good at
working with the four of us and that
could have taken forever doing those
things with someone who wasn't right for
it and I've seen that before if you get
three characters they don't know where
to put the camera and this was four
characters and everyone was learning
something in in the process of those
scenes especially the one where finally
all the information comes out
and everyone finally knows everything or
almost everything
um and that was I think great fun for
all of us is that we were all off
balance at the same time
and it was light bulbs were going off
all around the room as people were
keying into the reality of our situation
that was great fun as an ensemble that's
what you you kind of live for is that
and the ability to to play that
find the humor in it find the crazy
physical humor in in that scene was
great fun I couldn't wait to say I am
the company
I couldn't wait for that moment to
happen I just it delighted me and his
reaction was so much fun
well I hope I hope that this this
doesn't text him because that whole beat
was just so funny and such a beautiful
delivery so
um so with Howard and Monica they're
kind of at extremes where Howard is kind
of chasing that bloom of First Love
again and Monica is possibly the most
cynical person I've ever seen when it
comes to when it comes to romance and I
was wondering if it was these extremes
that kind of Drew you to the part or or
what it was that appealed to you
I think she's authentic and she's
realistic about a lot of things that
she's learned in in the deterioration of
of her relationship which is pretty
tragic I mean she is cynical but I mean
when you know there's a point where she
says and when did you first learn that
this wasn't true that love didn't
conquer everything and and and then
explains her philosophy and I think she
was a Believer at some point I think she
was a Believer and it slowly slipped
away for myriads of reasons that are her
fault and his fault and kids and
whatever
but it's fun to be disruptive you know
it's really fun to be that character who
says what are you saying
someone's kind of babbling on it's like
so I I knew I would have a good time I
thought I would have a good time if the
cast was right and I and I did
so Susan I have to ask
um you are going to be appearing in Blue
Beetle very shortly and I just wanted to
know what you were excited for fans to
see there my God to be in a in a comic
book and to be the bad guy
oh it was that was great and I had great
outfits and a you know I I wanted to be
a little bit more androgynous but that
scared them so we got I'm a little bit
more gentle but I'm that was really a
fun thing too that young director on
hell was fabulous and I mean we're
gushing a lot it sounds funny but really
that I I love
I love the enormity of it and um and the
kids were in it all the actors you you
know were
people that I because his whole family
is
um Mexican and they're all Mexican
actors and my henchman is Native
American so
um you know it was it was pretty unusual
Italians the first superhero movie that
stars uh uh Latino so that's pretty
special and he's great the kid's great
tying it back bringing it back I should
say to maybe I do
you mentioned that great moment of I am
the company but I was wondering
apart from that like what what highlight
what what was your favorite moment of
this of the of the movie your favorite
scene favorite conversation do you have
one I mean I like the scene where
everything explodes but I also like when
I'm threatening him and he just takes a
beat and says that's fair was that what
you say that's fair that's fair I mean
it's no it's hard to deliver those lines
in a way that really are funny and I
would that moment was I thought great
but of course the explosion of all the
information was a fun scene because we
were all together
Richard
what was your question I'm trying to
think of the
I think I like that the most I think I
like that the most and then when
everyone left I like the scene a lot
that that uh bill and I played
where we he wants to fight me and we're
circling each other and it's ridiculous
it's ridiculous it's ridiculous and I
calm him down and I give him a hug don't
get the whole movie
come on it's in the trailer oh anyhow